some days are going to be a 15-hour day
when you have a business because what
people that don't have businesses don't
realize is your business is the other
child you know and it's also the child
that feeds your actual child and so you
know I think that people are like oh man
like they can never say like oh my God
I'm gonna pick my business over my child
but the reality is there's not an
entrepreneur
planet that hasn't in the micro not in
the macro and so it's a game of not
beating yourself up brother like you
have God willing the next 70 years at
least maybe 80 given how young you are
in modern medicine to spend time with
that child you know nobody wants to miss
an hour here or now we're there who
wants to miss their kids first step or
their first word nobody wants to miss a
recital or a big game and you fight for
those things I always always fight for
those things welcome to office hours I'm
David Meltzer and I'm giddy because I
have what some people think is my best
friend he's actually said he was my best
friend I put it I made him say it and we
quoted it but Gary vaynerchuk is on
office hours garyvee as most people know
him welcome to office hours my friend
it's really nice to be with all of you
thank you for having me you're amazing
so
um I was sharing with everybody
entrepreneurship and how it's changed
over the years to be an entrepreneur
Gary when I I was young was like being
an actor if you told someone I'm an
entrepreneur regardless how successful
you were they're like so you wait tables
right
and you know thankfully I met you and I
have to admit I was in the Nike suite at
the Super Bowls it'll be five it'll be
six Super Bowls coming up to meet his
brother about a sports agency deal and
he came in and people Went Crazy Dave
he's here garyvee's here and I literally
said what's a garyvee and I thought
maybe it was a fourth round draft pick
that I missed
but he has truly created a brand for
entrepreneurs a heroic brand and I think
Gary my question is at a core everyone's
talking about this Lego video that
here's a guy who's leading the way of
Entrepreneurship and yet you're talking
about like two thousand dollars that you
made on eBay for Legos you know what is
it in your personality there's a
definition of a serial entrepreneur you
don't give a [ __ ] about how big the
project is you are completely obsessed
with the idea of buying and selling and
creating margins
and I'm obsessed with the responsibility
of having people be attached to the
message that I'm putting out there
beautiful in a time where I'm incredibly
concerned about
interest rates and how much VC money
there is and consumer confidence knowing
that people have all sorts of stuff in
their house that's worth money or the
ability to go to a garage sale tomorrow
and buy stuff that's worth money
inspires me and whether it's closing a
25 million dollar deal for vaynermedia
or buying something for a dollar and
selling it for seven dollars on eBay for
me it's one in the same game and when
you have millions of people following
you tens of millions of people following
you I I'm surprised by how many people
don't understand you have the
responsibility of providing value to
them not them giving you likes and
follows and and so for me to your point
I'll be as excited to make a video about
a CNBC article about flipping Legos as I
will about telling people four years ago
that if they bet the farm on Tick Tock
things can work out for them and
everything in between and
um while it's now 4 42 p.m on the East
Coast as we're filming this while
spending I don't know six hours today
with Fortune 100 companies on their
macro Global Marketing plans and so I
have a lot of flexibility in my
entrepreneurship now that I got the gray
hairs and I try to use all those skills
on a daily basis you're amazing chance
oh Gary love you man you have just given
me the permission to just promote
content and just put it out there and
get the message out there and you've
been an inspiration for me and my
entrepreneurial Journey for so long so
I'm honored to be here uh and ask you
some questions so I'm a new father uh I
have a one-year-old and I'm also our
business is growing very very quickly
and so I know you go all in with your
business and you're all over the place
on the road a ton how do you balance
that with your kids your family uh that
I just that's a big question for me
by not over judging myself and by being
aware that it's going to ebb and flow
you know
um some days are going to be a 15-hour
day when you have a business because
what people that don't have businesses
don't realize is your business is the
other child
you know and it's also the child that
feeds your actual child
and so you know I think that people are
like oh man like they can never say like
oh my God I'm gonna pick my business
over my child but the reality is there's
not an entrepreneur on the planet that
hasn't in the micro not in the macro and
so it's a game of not beating yourself
up brother like you have God willing the
next 70 years at least maybe 80 given
how young you are in modern medicine to
spend time with that child and so
you know nobody wants to miss an hour
here now where they are who wants to
miss their kids first step or their
first word nobody wants to miss a
recital or a big game and you fight for
those things I always always fight for
those things
but if the occasional scenario pops up
where I don't have the opportunity to
attend something because there's a
critical moment in a business that is
very important I'm not going to beat
myself up and say that I'm not a good
dad and you know I didn't even see my
dad the first 13 years of my life
because he worked so much because we
just came to America and he's the best
dad and we have the greatest
relationship so I'm as you can imagine
I'm not scared of it yeah yeah no thank
you and you know I had that conversation
with my my wife I was like babe we're on
we're on team well and like when when
you're at home and you're taking care of
the kid and yes those are those harder
times when I'm away you're allowing me
to go out there and have impact and meet
people and change the world and be able
to build our Legacy and so when you
think about it in that form like that's
really helped our relationship grow to
that next level like Hey we're doing
this together we're having impact
together even though you're sitting home
with the child and I'm out you know
hanging out with David melter and being
able to speak with you and get the
message out so it's like we're still
just all rowing in the same direction
and but realistic by the way oh by the
way oh by the way
like the luck the incredibleness of
raising a child is way cooler than
talking to garyvee and David Meltzer for
sure and but to that same point when
your kids get older and I have three
teenage 23 21 and 18 and one actually
works with me now you know just be
realistic they don't want to F and spend
all their time with you either you know
I beg for two minutes a day and I'm cool
with it yeah well that that starts
transitioning around 13 where kids
become the their friends become their
primary life not their parents so I will
say for young parents you know milk as
much as you can out of one through
thirteen Dave I'm sure you feel this I
already feel it in ways milk is much of
that time when we were the center of
their world because you're right it
flips you know for for value of pairing
I mean there's only I mean at this point
in my career the only person I can think
of that doesn't pick up my call is my
daughter
yeah she sees your name and she's an Fu
button to my dad exactly
because my dad is my favorite person now
and yeah I totally was just like oh my
God my dad and now it's like Dad let's
go to lunch
around Collins go ahead
so no I I believe that I appreciate that
sentence and I know that but in those
in-betweens you you know and so it's
just a big game of not over judging
yourself is really what we're all
talking about here and the next guy is
going to ask you a question I wanted to
get you together with because they have
an extraordinary company doing
extraordinary things in fact I think
they even have a Michael Bay movie for
you or something so we gotta after the
show make sure you get that introduction
column but for sure so Gary apart from
selling Legos on eBay you're obviously
uh most known for nfts which you said of
our game too and uh I just want to get
your opinions on the future of the nft
market because it's changed radically in
the last year or two and I see so much
more maturation in the market as well
um we're you know bringing we're
democratizing concerts and bringing them
to everyone around the world working
with A-list artists like Snoop Dogg and
like Alicia Keys and bringing them into
the world of web 3 and exploring how
they can reach new people and engage
with new audiences and interact with
their fans using you know the power of
nfts
um I think the days of the super
expensive pfps are you know more or less
behind us and now it's all about you
know community and club membership but I
just Gary I kind of wanted to understand
for me where you think it's going in the
future and uh and what we're going to
see over the next you know short to
medium term
short to medium term I don't even think
about
um so I don't think I have the best
guesses I think I was awfully right that
99 of the projects were going to go to
zero when I was yelling about that a
year ago in the height of the hype
because it wasn't sustainable
but the long term is very clear nfts are
digital contracts
um that have utility or
rights underneath them in the smart
contract and they will become a way of
life no different than apps and social
media and email and I think the consumer
blockchain will do for transactions what
the internet did for communication and
so I don't have a whole lot of
thoughts about the short term I I said 4
000 times a year ago and the nft market
right now is exactly what happened with
internet 99 there'll be a crash there'll
be two or three years of load them and
then the next generation of major
companies will pop up from that
you know low just like we saw with
Amazon and Google and all that stuff and
we're right on track you know
everybody's asking me about the market
and I've said the same thing I'm saying
when the market was ripping hot that I
am now the there'll be one percent
projects that are really meaningful some
of them will be about collectibility the
Andy Warhols and the Jackson Pollocks
and the Michael Jordan rookie cards and
the rare sneakers and the coins and the
Rolexes and the rare cars they'll be a
part in nft land for sure but the 99
will be about the contracts the access
tickets the receipts the membership
clubs and
um I think we're on track wonderful so
Gary I have loved you for many years
I've been following you and listening to
the stuff that you're spitting out and
just like that man is [ __ ] awesome
and then but then I didn't think I could
love you more but then you had a Persian
girlfriend and you know as persons we
stick together and I was like okay he is
the [ __ ] I literally went to my husband
and I was like he's dating a person look
and then I'm scrolling through her stuff
and I'm like Stephen
a lot of [ __ ] he was like that's because
you're the devil and I'm like
Gary thinks versions are awesome he was
just like oh my God okay I won Mary won
I'm like we're [ __ ] phenomenal so I
have one serious question and then one
kind of silly one what is it about uh
her culture that you love the most
what's your favorite thing
funny like the Persian culture in the
Russian culture share a lot of things
caviar tea like you know family oriented
respect your elders very very family so
I would say that I've always you know
Russian and Persian culture have a long
history of having a lot of similarities
including both were incredibly beautiful
countries that had very aggressive
revolutions uh you know Russia's lasted
from 1917 to 1989 1991 depending on when
you think that USSR fell you know
obviously there's so much going on in
Iran right now it it fell to a
revolution in 1979 and so there's a lot
of connection points
um I feel very close to that's beautiful
I mean even even Nikolai volkov and the
Iron Sheik were tag team partners
you always could take it where you want
to go I know I know so I had a serious
question if I may yeah I thought that
one was seriously well that one was
mostly like I just want to understand I
know as I'm you know burning his mouth
with tea I have to put an ice cube in
for him
um that being said my serious question
was earlier you said that we have to be
kinder to ourselves and if it made me
wonder do you believe in balance or Do
You Believe In Harmony in our lives in
our businesses everywhere that we
operate
I think both words are just semantics
the answer is yes I believe in harm I
love when I'm like I I wish you a joyous
day and then in my Twitter they're like
oh I'm sorry I wish you a happy day and
then in the third reply my Twitter's
like [ __ ] happiness you should go for
Joy right
we're saying the same [ __ ]
right like like I Believe In Harmony I
Believe In Balance I Believe In Joy but
like what's one's harm like balance is
impossible like everyone's like you need
balance I'm like cool what's your
balance yeah because my balance is
different what's one's Joy one's one to
happiness what I want is
at its core what's become very tangible
to me is I want people to live their
life with as little anxiety as humanly
possible the way I do when I look at
myself today and look at everybody
around me and when I mean around me very
close to me but then the next layer of
my family then my co-workers then my
friends then then the hardest core fans
them casual fans I'm looking at a lot of
groups of people
and like when I say to myself like
what's the most different thing about me
the most different thing about me is the
percentage of my time
that my stomach feels anxiety the number
is almost non-existent
and I mean almost non-existent for the
year in a world where I watch almost
everyone I know have percentages during
every day some 80 of their day
even inversely before and so I am
obsessed
with being a communicator to try to
change people's perspectives because
living life with anxiety
nerves insecurity concern fear
dwelling
indifference apathy
is really like
not the way to play this gift called
life
Gary how do you like I'm going into some
spiritual crazy pieces in my mind that
are practical like oh wait a minute
maybe the answer is if you're not happy
you have to go crazy simplistic and like
move to Peru and work on a farm
because then you just reset the whole
thing and get into a simple State
because a stunning amount of people
that live a very simple life with very
little income in second and third world
countries have remarkable happiness
all the time and so if you're not cut
out for the muscle and bustle of a first
world country then cool who gives a [ __ ]
just because I am I don't think that
makes me special or good I just think it
fits my DNA but for you maybe you should
go to
and lived there full time like I'm
really like going there like I'm really
challenging my self to figure [ __ ] out
the world and then talk about it like
I'm into it that's what I want to do
so we're so it's interesting because
I've I've kind of just done that
um
yeah I'm Irish but I live I've been
living in four years in Dubai and don't
get me wrong it's incredible place and
it's the hustle bustle and the glitz and
the Glam but I moved to Brazil and you
know it's it's a long way away from
Dubai but my health has improved my
happiness has improved my work-life
balance is so much better
um and you know yeah I can be on the in
Dubai on this incredible Beach drinking
a 20 beer but I'm just as happy on
plastic Furniture drinking a two dollar
beer you know surrounded by a whole lot
more normal people and it is
reinvigorating I mean I am I understand
that more you know and for me
living this high intensity life is like
laying on a plastic piece of furniture
drinking a zero dollar beer like it's
all like I don't even I'm not attached
to my career my notoriety my financial
success I'm not attached to it I have no
self-worth tied up in garyvee or Gary
vaynerchuk the entrepreneur my
self-worth is fully and utterly 100
attached to how I treat human beings
wow and you live that but it's
interesting Gary because you have to
evolve to that and I think people want
to cheat themselves on the steps that it
takes and so I meet religious people
well David I'll I'll tell you I would
argue that
I didn't evolve into it that of course I
did to your point but
I've always been it what I mean by that
is I'm trying to tell people like you
and I David grew up in the generation
where the world told you what success
was right
I never got caught in it because I was
weird from the get I talk a lot about
having my fingers and my ears and being
weird about school right [ __ ] school and
everyone thinks that's kind of cool what
people understand that they don't think
is as cool
is I did that for the definition of
success
like I didn't think I needed a fancy car
or a fancy house or a Rolex like I
treated The Glitz and glamor of
capitalism the same way I treated school
which is you're both full of [ __ ] yeah I
wish I did yeah it it yet the anxiety
part that there has to be I think an
education itself that it's not a matter
of how much anxiety you put towards or
attach emotion to an outcome that you're
not there yet and there has to be some
sort of uh look at the journey and you
know I watch Gary a lot not not for the
content itself but for that idea of
being at ease while everyone thinks
you're not like if you take a brand and
say this guy goes out and he's like a
pit bull in a china shop no he's
actually Buddhist if you really examine
not the con like the words but
understand that like he's on a mission
to change the world knowing that all
Tides move to the lowest point of
humility and although the daily
activities seem very rigorous he's at
ease and that's how even last night Gary
we were at dinner and everyone's like
you're 54 years old how do you have more
energy than me and I said well we all
have the same energy you're interfering
with it right you interfere with the
need to be right offended separate
inferior Superior 100 I I've been on
this hot kick lately with my content I'm
I'm on a new you know you get caught on
certain things you want to talk about
this concept of grudges is on my mind in
a way that you can't imagine
this concept of grudges might be the
most reverse thing I've like I'm really
tapped in right now people hold a grudge
and actually think the person they're
holding the grudge against is getting
hurt right
but they're getting eaten alive
by holding the grudge
it's it's profound to me and that goes
into energy if you're spending all your
energy paying attention to the person
that you're mad at to hope that they are
more hurt because you're hurt by them
you've got no energy for yourself to
find your happiness
I told you he's Buddhist
all right who has the last question for
G as we let him go
um so I just want to know what are your
thoughts on the the future of Education
a lot of us here talking about the
Educational Systems broken here at
abundance.io we teach people how to
create Business Online trying to shorten
that gap between
um you know information download to
being able to apply it and have some SEC
some success in some fact or another I
know that it's evolved to online a bit
but where do you see the evolution of
Education going in the next three to
five years
three to five years I think it's going
to be small little steps a couple more
people AKA thousands of ten thousand
more people are going to take their kids
homeschooling a couple more people AKA
thousands to ten thousand people are
gonna let their kids mail in the core
education so that they can spend an hour
or two when they get home on something
that's digital but I think in a 15-year
window in a 20-year window you're
looking at substantial substantial
changes I believe gen Z
call it 16 to 22 year olds today are the
generation that won't make their kids go
to college
so
maybe it's another 20 years where that
they start having children and so then
another 20 so you know you know kids
people are having kids a little bit
later they're 20 now let's just give it
10 18. I would say in 25 years you're
going to see a substantial
substantial fall off the cliff moment of
college uh college kids and I think that
will trickle them down to high school
and grammar school and I think the
revolution the cat's out of the bag at
this point and over the next three
decades we will see transformation more
vocational like we used to do it in the
50s parents are going to be more not
ideological more practical so hey my kid
loves being a mechanic like let them
learn to be a mechanic now the reason
I'm a great entrepreneur is my mom let
me be an entrepreneur from 8 to 18. I
came out guns are blazing at 20 you know
people hear myself
you know like I was a I was a veteran by
the time I was they're like wow at 22
you built your dad's business so fast
how I was a [ __ ] 14-year veteran in
business by then you know that's how
and so I think we're going to see that I
think we're gonna see more skill sets
more Alternative Learning
um it's just so obvious the world's
changing rapidly yeah
and we need more of garyvee and in case
you didn't know what a garyvee was you
now do
and uh he has blessed us all Gary
vaynerchuk
I am honored to be your best friend at
least for this show
[Laughter]
his best friend make sure you get that
content the guy taught me this thing hi
everyone Take Care thank you Gary okay
thank you
foreign
[Music]